IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERING)
SO... A HUGE PERK OF DOING THE
SHOW IN NEW YORK IS ALL THE
ICONIC NEW YORK CELEBRITIES WHO
WANT TO DROP BY THE SHOT, LIKE,
OH, I DON'T KNOW, UH... STEPHEN
COLBERT!
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, STEPHEN
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
I SAID, UH...
STEPHEN COLBERT!
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
>> NO, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
>> UH, BUDDY, I APOLOGIZE.
I AM JUST WAY TOO SWAMPED THIS
WEEK TO GET OUT TO L.A.
HAVE A GREAT SHOW, THOUGH.
>> HARDWICK: NO, ACTUALLY,
STEPHEN, WE'RE IN NEW YORK.
WE'VE BEEN IN NEW YORK ALL WEEK.
WE'RE NOT IN L.A.
>> RIGHT. YEAH, SURE.
WELL, REGARDLESS OF THE WHERE,
THE FACT IS, I DON'T HAVE A SHOW
TOMORROW AND I HAVE TO GET READY
FOR THAT.
>> HARDWICK: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
'CAUSE YOU'RE LITERALLY, LIKE,
RIGHT DOWN THE HALL.
YOU COULDN'T JUST POP IN?
>> MEETINGS, CHRIS.
FULL DAY OF MEETINGS.
I WISH I COULD GET OUT OF IT,
BUT I BELIEVE IT WAS SHAKESPEARE
WHO WROTE, "WHEN IN DISGRACE
WITH FORTUNE AND MEN'S EYES, I
ALL ALONE BEWEEP MY OUTCAST
STATE AND TROUBLE DEAF HEAVEN
WITH MY BOOTLESS CRIES, AND LOOK
UPON MYSELF AND CURSE MY...
FATE...
(WHOOPING, CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
...WISHING ME..."
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE CONTINUE)
>> HARDWICK: HEY.
>> HEY, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> HARDWICK: NICE TO SEE YOU.
GOOD MEETING.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE CONTINUE)
>> HEY...
ABSOLUTELY. CHRIS HARDWICK,
EVERYBODY, CHRIS HARDWICK.
HEY, CHRIS HOW ARE...
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MAN.
THANKS FOR STOPPING BY.
>> HARDWICK: NO, THANK YOU,
YEAH, YOU'RE BUSY, I GET IT...
>> YEAH, I AM. YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: COULD YOU PLEASE
JUST INTRODUCE TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
WARS LIKE YOU SAID YOU WOULD?
>> AW, CHRIS, I WOULD LOVE TO,
BUT I'M SUPER CRUNCHED FOR TIME
HERE.
>> HARDWICK: UH... I WILL GIVE
YOU 60-- ONE, 20-- $60.
>> IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
♪
(CHEERING, WHISTLING, APPLAUSE)
>> IN HONOR OF MY
CLOSE PERSONAL FRIEND CHRIS
HARDWICK'S VISIT TO NEW YORK,
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS...
HASHTAG NYCIN3WORDS.
EXAMPLES ARE... THE BIG APPLE,
THIN CRUST PIZZA, AND...
COLBERT'S TOWN, BITCH.
(LAUGHTER)
(WHOOPING, APPLAUSE)
>> HARDWICK: THANK YOU, STEPHEN
COLBERT, FOR BEING SO GENEROUS
WITH YOUR TIME.
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, COMEDIANS, 60
SECONDS, AND GO!
JESSE JOYCE.
>> NO, FUCK YOU!
(LAUGHTER, CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
WHOA!
WOW.
JIM NORTON.
>> EBOLA DOCTOR BOWLING.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JESSE JOYCE.
>> IT'S ME!
>> JUMP, YOU PUSSY!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
KURT.
>> NO HOT WATER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JIM.
>> GAY BATHHOUSE OVERPRICED.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
KURT.
>> DOMINICANS ALLOWED.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
I LIVE IN WASHINGTON HEIGHTS.
>> HARDWICK: JIM.
>> BIKE LANES ABOMINATION.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
KURT METZGER.
>> BEATEN BY ELMO.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JESSE JOYCE.
>> ONLY IN NEW...
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
KURT METZGER.
>> EAT PRAY MURDER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
KURT METZGER.
>> DON'T DEFEND BROOKLYN!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
JESSE.
>> EVERY PUERTO RICAN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. EXCELLENT!